uh morphic resonance experiments are
also possible
in the human realm um it's
it's hard to set up morphic resonance
experiments online because
what you're trying to do in morphic
resonance is seeing if a skill gets
easier as time goes on is it getting
easier to learn skateboarding
windsurfing snowboarding
skydiving etc the problem is in real
world grouper could it be something like
teaching a brand
could it be like a brand new sport
because skateboarding and all these
other sports are already
they're known but if we made up a new
sport
in some random location across the
planet and then
the general idea is that if i picked
people of approximately same
cognitive capacity and in in one part of
the planet and we taught them a brand
new never been thought of before sports
and then we picked other people of the
general similar cognitive capacity
and when we measured the time that it
took them to learn this brand new sport
that no one's
ever heard of and that's the idea of how
we could do that
absolutely they should be able to learn
it quicker but the problem is you know i
spend a lot of time thinking about
experiments and
the the problem with this particular one
is that now
everything is so interconnected with the
internet that
if you train a group of people and you
say look we're training you this really
new sport no one else has ever done in
the world
within seconds one of them is going to
have it on instagram hey guys i'm
learning this place for a sport
and it's going to go all over the world
so um
the only way of actually doing this
would be to have a group of people who
really are
cut off from the rest of the world you
know
prisoners for example or have it done
right away
like if you if you take and just and you
ask them hey guys
just for the rest of the day don't um
post about this on on the internet quite
yet
even though that is like our extended
phenotype in a sense but just
don't post about it on the internet yet
and then have the group in
you know if we're doing this in texas
and then we have somebody
in oxford and somebody in melbourne that
it that are that are also going to do it
just
literally 15 minutes after the one in
texas completed
yeah that's good a good idea and
actually where this would
probably be it would probably be easiest
to do using some kind of new video game
which involves some kind of new skill
that you have to learn
to do the video game so this could be
built into some kind of new gaming
platform
um where you could have a completely new
thing in a video game whether you have
to solve particular problems
um that um no one solved before
and then it might be possible to get
people doing it
15 minutes later in melbourne australia
and that sort of thing
and see if they do it quicker okay like
like a sort of in
in a sense it would be like if i'm
entering into a game because i'm a huge
i'm a huge gamer um and have been and
i think a lot of people around the world
are because it kind of creates a
an idea of a deeper idea about who we
truly
are and how this is already virtual
reality but we'll get there in a moment
the idea is that it could be the
immersion into a game where
i have to do a a never-before-done
puzzle of sorts and i and i do that
never before done
puzzle and then immediately as soon as
i'm done they're triggered in a
different country around the world the
next person begins doing the puzzle
then the next person and these are
gamers that have generally the same
cognitive capacity
and generally the same uh dexterity and
video game
um uh capacities their their abilities
have been trained
so it's not like somebody that has never
held a game controller before versus
somebody that has
yeah that's right well maybe the beer
people who do this might have to do some
kind of preliminary test to show that
they're up to a certain level of skill
yes um or there are certain games have
levels anyway
pick people who are at a certain level
um
anyway the point is with large samples
it doesn't really
matter about matching them too much you
can do things with
you know if you've got thousands of
people taking part
yeah the individual differences tend to
cancel out with very large samples
as long as there's not a systematic bias
in favor of
smart people doing it first and less
smart people doing it
so rupert would you say that um i see
where i see where you're going there
that's that's beautiful so
the idea is that if we could recruit
just a thousand people around the world
to to do the same puzzle
that's never been done before but that
we make this we design this puzzle
and then we kind of have a domino effect
of the 1000 people in different
countries around the world as soon as
the first person is done
it's a brief puzzle maybe it only takes
a minute um to get it done or two
minutes or whatever
and then the next person starts it the
next person starts as soon as the other
one finishes
and the idea would be that generally
speaking
it should be if the first person takes
four minutes to get it done
by the end of the 1000 the last person
should be getting it done in one minute
or something like that there should be a
significant increase
well it would be the points would be
scattered you know it should be like
drawing a graph through scattered points
you know the statistical techniques tell
you if you can see a significant
trend would there be a significant trend
towards it getting easier
you can statistics enables you to deal
with individual differences when you're
looking for trends
so you'd be looking for a trend and then
i mean the more people the better
actually if you're doing
the trend i mean there is i i think this
would be
a a brilliant way of testing morphic
[Music]
i'm not a gamer myself and i don't know
people who
program games but i can help
i can help yeah i rupert the reason why
we
you know we have these conversations
also is not only for people
to get um inspired about pushing
beyond the edge of what's known like
what you're doing and
signing up at sheldrake.org for the
joint detention study and the telephone
telepathy study
but also you know for them to design the
games
and then for them to do these new
studies
around the world that can begin proving
this rupert we're gonna carry
the flag very strong moving forward and
and and i agree that i think through
games especially
i mean there's so many uh
even in the last five years there's so
many i know that
um you know stanford and and harvard and
uh ucsf and so many places
around the world have started doing
where you just take your
your device you you take you take your
device
and it's something as simple as just
getting that
that uh that notification that there's
a new game that a new puzzle
where we're doing a test of morphic
resonance and and
you know you get the notification and
and you and you do the
you do the puzzle and you're part of the
study and you might get paid
you know uh five bucks for participating
it because we got a grant
from an ultra high net worth family
around the planet that is very
interested
in this exact phenomenon and so
this is the future that we're ushering
and this is a big central part of
of this project and so it's totally
available today to do things like that
oh great well i mean anything you can do
to help this along alan would be very
very welcome that would be great
um i think this would be astonishingly
interesting yeah we we have the tools
now
to to do so um rupert i have a guys
a call to action get something like this
out into the world
faster um and and uh
and let's find out these these what's
beyond the edge of what's currently
known and let's test it
scientifically and in a fun and engaging
way like through
like through solving puzzles and games
and things like that this is a really
fun part of
of the conversation rupert